they say that this is the best Android
phone in the world so how does it
compare to the best iPhone well today we
are going to compare everything from the
design the displays the performance
speakers thermals cameras and more this
year is an interesting one for Samsung
because the s24 ultra actually copies
quite a bit from the iPhone we have
similar pull tabs but they don't want to
work Samsung's constantly making fun of
Apple but they keep copying it and the
s24 ultra didn't change that much but
the things that did change are very
weird ones now right away looking at the
color my goodness this looks so similar
to Apple's natural color slightly warmer
but right away this thing feels
different in the hand the sides are flat
with a subtle curve just like the iPhone
and now the display is flat as well
Samsung for years really cared about
that curve but they switched and I have
to say it looks and it feels nice now
the frame is also made out of titanium
just like the iPhone I like that it used
aluminum before it's lighter and this
thing actually is just only 1 G lighter
than before even though it did get a
little smaller in thinner and even
though they made fun of Apple's 5x
camera compared to their 10x they've had
for years they now have a 5x camera
which will take a look at in just a bit
it is a little bit larger and heavier
than the iPhone and it also costs $100
more but with that said you do get that
S Pen built in and if you actually use
it it is nice but personally it just
stays in the phone for me now the one
thing that I wish they would have copied
from Apple is ma safe with the new ch2
standard but they did not build magnets
into the phone like you can get on the
iPhone which makes it really nice and
convenient but thankfully our sponsor
Taurus has you covered with their o
stand case that really makes this phone
Ultra it's basically a case a stand a
ring and Mac safe allinone instantly
making your s24 Ultra or any other phone
support Max safe accessories like car
chargers or chat2 power Banks and it can
now magnetically stick to metal surfaces
the stand aspect ratio is great since
you can prop it up in vertical mode to
take selfies or watch shorts as well as
landscape mode for movies or videos you
can also use the ring as a finger grip
and the case itself self is very
protective and durable with raised edges
to protect the cameras while being very
slim at the same time Taurus also has
their Diamond Shield screen protector
which is incredibly easy to install in
three simple steps and it gives you
solid protection with 9h hardness
tempered glass smooth touch no color
deviations and high touch sensitivity so
definitely pick these up for your new
s24 Ultra by using the link in the
description below now looking at the
fronts I love how the new s24 Ultra
looks with that flat screen we now have
even bezels all around super thin and
it's a really nice clean look of course
the iPhone has those curved edges also
with even bezels but one thing the
iPhone doesn't have is that tiny little
cutout instead of that large dynamic
Island now Samsung and Apple keep
trading blows in terms of speaker
quality so let's go ahead and compare
this new one somewhere
unfamiliar bring me back to where we
started out
[Music]
me out
of you guys let me know your thoughts
down below but one difference that I
noticed is BAS the Bas in this new
Samsung is not really there I feel like
the old one sounded better maybe cuz
they made it thinner I'm not sure but
overall I would say the iPhone does
sound better getting into into displays
one thing that I noticed is how much
darker the display is in the black areas
than the iPhone now I actually took off
the screen protectors to make sure
nothing was affecting it and the Samsung
has really really good antireflectivity
which is why the colors are so rich and
dark now I maxed out the brightness on
both because the Samsung is now rated up
to
2,600 nits better than the 2000 of the
iPhone and looking at them it does seem
like the Samsung is brighter just
manually maxing it out dang guys this is
bright and this is actually a first
where the Samsung can actually beat it
in a full white test and then going
outside in the sun you could see how
much brighter the Samsung is than the
iPhone it is actually really impressive
I thought the iPhone was the best at
this and it was but the Samsung looks
like it's years ahead especially because
of the nice antireflectivity cating it
just looks amazing it makes the Iphone
honestly look bad and watching this HDR
movie here it looks incredible on the
Samsung the whole screen is brighter we
have better contrast no issues with
reflectivity I mean it is really amazing
I like the larger screen and we don't
have the dynamic Island uh you actually
have the full screen being used that
because of the aspect ratio if I was
watching a movie I would absolutely want
to watch on the Samsung I mean we just
can't get over how incredible this
display looks and now let's get into
performance and the first thing I want
to test is the storage speed because
apple is starting to fall
behind oh my
goodness okay guys so we have
1,514 for re on the iPhone compared to
2,746 that is like MacBook Pro level of
performance now for the right we have
406 compared to
1,575 dang that is fast now in terms of
CPUs we have the 3 nmet a17 Pro compared
to the 4 nanometer Snapdragon 8 gen 3 8
gigs compared to 12 of ram let's go
ahead and run our CPU Benchmark all
right guys this is crazy in terms of
single core score we have a difference
of
28% but in multicore score it is
practically the same we have a
difference of 83 points that's within
margin of error and we have a 4 nmet
chip here in this phone that is
performing so dang good that is
impressive and now let's take a look at
Graphics I have 3D Marks Wildlife
extreme unlimited here but we'll also do
a ray tracing test after and here we
have
21.7 compared to 28 8.6 frames per
second that's a difference of
32% so the iPhone is getting destroyed
now both of these do have Ray tracing so
we have this new test called solar Bay
let's go ahead and run it now that test
just finished running on the Samsung so
we've been benchmarking these I want to
compare the temps um I'm seeing 39° C on
the Samsung and on the iPhone
42 right over there dang and you guys
can see the hotspot the Samsung is
definitely running cooler now with that
they actually updated their whole
thermal system you have twice uh the
vapor chamber that's built into there so
we have better graphics performance that
I showed you guys and it's going to stay
cooler for longer now we have a results
from solar Bay right here and we have
5,969 compared to 8,00 267 overall score
that is a
38% difference even greater this time
meaning that the rate tracing on the
Samsung is probably better than what
Apple just finally added and looking at
the frame rates you guys can see all the
details there um definitely much better
on the Samsung so if you care about
gaming go for that and now let's talk
about the cameras both phones kept most
of the lenses from last year but they
each got a new new 5x Zoom now in this
first shot this is actually a 2X
portrait crop and as you guys could see
there's some differences in color um
some brightness on the face I don't
think either one looks great and here's
an ultra wide shop both are 12 megapixel
so let's see if we have any difference
in
detail um honestly the iPhone looks
better this is really waxy but the HDR
does look slightly better comparing the
selfie shots Samsung's has higher
resolution
and honestly I love how it looks
brighter nice and crisp but you guys let
me know your thoughts and now let's look
at the 5x lenses Samsung had a 10x
forever now it's 5 but it's 50 megapixel
compared to 12 this shot looks very
similar here but if we go ahead and zoom
in a little bit and we look at the
detail I don't know guys it doesn't look
that much better to me and this is in
really good lighting same thing with
with this water tower or cell phone
stuff on top yeah it looks a little bit
more detailed but also looks a little
bit
oversharpened um in the Rocks I don't
know maybe they should have stayed with
the 10x lens and here we have a 200
megapixel shot compared to the
48 and we definitely have a little bit
more detail but also more noise now as
you guys know we love doing the blind
camera comparison test because we have a
a wide variety of images and we have to
guess without knowing which phone is
which so make sure you guys are
subscribed cuz we will be doing that
soon so to answer the original question
can the s24 ultra defeat the iPhone 15
Pro Max well I think we have to agree
with VI yes we were very impressed with
the phone overall and add to that the
fact that you do have an S Pen if you
want to use it a lot of new AI features
and we have Wi-Fi 7 built in as well
with the new modem this is definitely
the superior smartphone now uh software
wise you can argue about that down in
the comment section below but we give
this phone a big thumbs up so go ahead
and click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there this been Max and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one